Um es mit den Worten von einem gewissen Marc S zu sagen, die zweite Liga ist so weg. Und wir sind es auch. Marc und ich sprechen jetzt über die neue Saison in der zweiten Bundesliga der Männer und stellen euch das neue Format vor. Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor! Und Augsburg ist oben! Kroffi zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf! Wagner, Martin Wagner!
Und das 1-0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Hallo Leute, ist das schön, wieder dieses Intro zu hören. Ich hab's vermisst und damit herzlich willkommen zurück bei der Ligatour. Ich bin Eva Lottabohle. Ich bin 50% vom Moderator in dem Team der Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Ihr könnt mich sonst noch bei 11 Freunde am Abend hören. Und ich freue mich wirklich, wirklich sehr, dass es heute zu einer Mini-Premiere in diesem Format kommt. Denn ich darf endlich an meiner Seite die anderen 50% des Teams begrüßen. Marc Schwitzki, hallo!
Ja, gehe ich komplett mit und ich muss einfach sagen, ja, nicht, dass ich das Ergebnis erwartet hatte, aber ja, der Kader birgt halt eben in der Defensive für mich ja ganz große Probleme, weil ich habe halt nicht das Gefühl, dass die Probleme, die in der ersten Liga existiert haben, nur mit Kevin Vogt hier oben werden können. Also du hast mit Bernardo Oehmer und Oddez III in Verteidiger verloren. Vogt sollte eben diese große Stabilisierung, weiß ich nicht, Ruhrpol sein, aber damit behäbst du halt keine Defensivprobleme auf lange Zeit mit einem einzelnen Spieler. Und ich sehe bei Bochum einfach, ich weiß es nicht, ich sehe da einfach auch immer noch Probleme mit Hacking als Trainer. Ich weiß, dass super viele von ihm überzeugt sind und sagen, in der 2. Liga läuft es anders, aber man muss auch einfach sagen, er kommt ja nicht frisch rein als Trainer in der 2. Liga, sondern er ist mit dieser Bochumer Mannschaft abgestiegen und am Ende auch vollkommen verdient abgestiegen.
Aber hast du nicht das Gefühl, dass man das sehr von seiner Person trennen kann, weil es davor eigentlich schon in die Binsen gegangen ist und eher so ein Himmelsfahrtskommando angetreten ist?
Ja, aber ich hatte halt immer das Gefühl, dass es auch immer wieder Diskussionen gab, ob man mit ihm jetzt wirklich weitermacht oder nicht. Und ich habe manchmal so quer gelesen auf Blue Sky oder so, was die Bochum-Fans da sagen. Und da sind einfach viele Leute mit den taktischen Entscheidungen, die er in einem Spiel fällt, also beziehungsweise davor und auch im Spiel, einfach nicht zufrieden. Und man muss einfach sagen, also Darmstadt ist unter Kohfeldt für mich– wir haben es jetzt so oft schon gehört– hat auch irgendwie immer eine Black Box. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich von denen in so einer Saison… Du kannst alles bekommen von denen. Und da muss ich einfach sagen, ja, es ist auch einfach brutal, als Absteiger nach Darmstadt zu reisen am ersten Spieltag. Also in der zweiten Liga gibt es keine einfachen Gegner. Aber es gibt sicherlich auch angenehmere Punkte in die Saison zu starten. Aber ich sehe sie einfach nicht als Aussteiger. Ich glaube einfach, sie haben halt die meiste Bundesliga-Erfahrung von allen Mannschaften in der zweiten Liga. Das ist einfach so aus den letzten fünf Jahren. Und daran werden sie halt auch gemessen werden. Und dafür sehe ich da einfach im Kader viel zu viele Probleme.
Also ich bin, also auch da wieder sehr legitimer Standpunkt und kann definitiv so kommen. Ich habe sie tatsächlich auf meinen Platz 3 getippt. Aber auch in dem Sinne mit Bauchschmerzen, weil ich mich bei diesem letzten Aufstiegsplatz so ehrisch schwergetan habe. Das hättest du würfeln können bei so drei, vier Kandidaten. Mein ausschlaggebender Punkt war, ich finde schon, wenn der Kader einigermaßen so jetzt bis zum Ende der Transferperiode zusammenbleiben sollte und dann auch gewisse Spieler fit werden, Gerrit Holtmann, Unjeka, Quateng, Erhan Masovic, super wichtig für die Abwehr. Wenn diese Spieler dann fit werden und reinkommen, dann finde ich, ist das schon ein Kader, der besser ist als viele in der zweiten Liga. Ich finde, dass du, also bei Broschinski ist die große Frage, ob er bleibt. Wenn er bleibt, kann er ein wirklich guter Stürmer in der zweiten Liga sein. Zusammen auch im Doppelpass dann mit Philipp Hofmann, der diese Liga in- und auswendig kennt. Sie haben im Mittelfeld interessante Jungs, auch in KAW beispielsweise ausgeliehen. Francis Onjeka ist an sich jemand, der hochtalentiert ist. Und ich finde, dass du auch auf der Außenverteidiger-Position Spieler hast, die in der ersten Liga vielleicht nicht sonderlich gut waren, die in der zweiten Liga aber richtig gut sein können. Ich finde, Maximilian Wittek kann einer der besten Linksverteidiger dieser Liga sein, mit seinem Offensiv-Rang, mit seiner Flankenqualität. Kann sein. Das ist aber natürlich viel konjunktiv, das sehe ich schon. Auch, wie gesagt, ist die Frage, bleibt Matthias Speerow, bleibt Ibrahima Sissoko, das sind natürlich noch so Fragezeichen dieser Kader.
Ibrahima Sissoko und Ibrahim Sissoko, nicht zu verwechseln, die beiden.
Ja, der eine hat ein I und der andere hat ein I. Punkt, das ist völlig wild, was da auf dem Trikot passiert ist. Aber lassen wir das an der Stelle. Also, du hast viel auch Potenzial, was sich in der Saison entwickeln kann. Leandro Morgalla beispielsweise, auch ein junger, talentierter Innenverteidiger. Ich finde erst mal die Mischung des Kaders gut. Und ich glaube, dass Dieter Hecking relativ schnell Ruhe in den Kader bekommen könnte. Und auch das ist in einer zweiten Liga sehr wichtig. Denn irgendwann fängst du dann an, konstant zu punkten und vielleicht mal den einen Punkt mitzunehmen, den dein Konkurrent nicht mitnimmt. Und ich glaube, dahingehend könnte Dieter Hecking ein guter Trainer sein. Aber du hast es angesprochen, es sind auch viele Spieler gegangen. Es gibt Fragezeichen im Kader, das sehe ich alles. Ich sehe nur das Potenzial dafür, dass sich ein paar Fragezeichen auch in Ausrufezeichen entwickeln könnten. Und dann hat Bochum einen wirklich stabilen Kader für diese Liga.
Ja, ich glaube, mein Hauptproblem ist einfach, dass ich, also Großteil des Kaders ist halt immer noch da geblieben. Und das kann halt auch richtig in die falsche Richtung gehen. Weil, again, das sind Spieler, die haben alle in den letzten Jahren auch viel Bundesliga gespielt. Und sowas kann auch immer dazu führen, dass dann Spieler denken, naja, aber also ich könnte jetzt, also ja, nicht Bundesliga-Spieler. So und ich habe es schon bei Vereinen gesehen, die eben abgestiegen sind. Und das kann immer, das kann wirklich immer in beide Richtungen führen. Entweder sind die sagen, okay, wir wollen da wieder hin mit genau diesem Verein. Oder sie sagen halt, gut, ich spiele jetzt eine halbe Saison so, dass mich dann halt in der Winterpause ein Bundesligist wiederholt. Weil sie sehen, ich bin halt einer der besseren Spieler aus diesem Zweite-Liga-Kader. Und das ist halt für mich die große Krux, ob das passieren wird bei Bochum. Und das ist eben auch die große Gefahr. Und die sehe ich halt nicht eins zu eins so bei Kiel, weil sie eben nur ein Jahr Bundesliga gespielt haben und eben generell einen anderen Kaderaufbau hatten. Und das ist, glaube ich, meine Bauchschmerzen damit, wo ich einfach denke, das kann halt auch richtig schief laufen. Und du kannst eben auch in die Fußstapfen von– ist zu beleid– aber Hertha, Schalke, HSV und Co. treten und da eben dann den Wiederaufstieg nicht schaffen.
Die Gefahr besteht definitiv. Aber dann kommen wir vielleicht zu dem anderen Team, Darmstadt. Das habe ich als in etwa gleich gut eingeschätzt. Aber auch da das KSC-Argument und das jetzt schon oft genutzte Wort Black Box. Das hast du auch schon gesagt. Mein erster Vergleich nach diesem 4 zu 1 war– ja, das würde mich überhaupt nicht wundern, wenn sie im nächsten Spiel– das ist dann übrigens gegen Nürnberg– 4 zu 1 verlieren. Absolut möglich! Das ist wirklich krass. Das hat man ja auch letzte Saison gesehen. Das ist so ein– dieses Krofeld Darmstadt ist so hot and cold, das entweder rasiert das drei Spiele durch oder verliert vier und sieht aus wie ein Aufsteiger. Das ist wirklich krass. Also, der Kader ist aktuell individuell gut besetzt. Sollte Liedberg bleiben, hast du einen der besten Stürmer dieser Liga. Das ist ein Faustpfand. Und sie haben jetzt mit Marco Richter– also, Marco Richter, finde ich, hat in diesem ersten Spiel bewiesen, dass er in Normalform und wenn er sich wohlfühlt, ein richtig guter Spieler ist für die zweite Liga.
Aber Marco Richter ist für mich Darmstadt als Spieler, weil auch Marco Richter ist eine absolute Blackbox.
Ich kenne das ja von Hertha, genau. Also, mal hat er aus 40 Metern das Ding in Winkel gejagt oder er war nicht existent. Das ist so. Und so war es ja beim HSV stückweit auch bei seiner Leie. Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ihm Kohfeldt jetzt im ersten Spiel echt viele Freiheiten gelassen hat. Und das tut Marco Richter gut. Und der hatte da ein, zwei Szenen, also wie er quasi das, ich glaube, zweite Tor einleitet. Da lässt er einen Spieler von Bochum super aussteigen und spielt eine perfekte Flanke auf vorn, wie der den Ball in den Pfosten köpft und dann macht den Dietberg rein. Mega-Szene. Und ich glaube, dass solche Momente könnten den Unterschied machen. Sie haben keine Stamm-Spieler verloren, keine wichtigen Spieler verloren, haben mit Patrick Pfeiffer einen guten Inverteiger gewonnen, haben in Japan zweimal zugeschlagen. Das hatte sich in den letzten Jahren oft ausgezahlt für deutsche Vereine, wie ich finde, auch wenn ich diese Spieler erst mal per se nicht einschätzen kann. Der Kader ist sehr stabil in seiner Grundform. Da bleiben die Clemens Riedels dieser Welt immer noch. Marcel Schuhn ist da immer noch. Fabian Holland ist jetzt sogar zurückgekehrt und kann für ein Jahr noch ein bisschen Stabilität bringen. Ich denke auf keinen Fall, dass die im Aufstiegsrennen wirklich ein Wort mitreden werden. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie mal den kleinen C reinhalten. Aber am Ende eher etwas um Rang 7 erreichen. Auch das finde ich ist für eine Darmstädter Saison mehr als in Ordnung. Dementsprechend sind sie aber, wie ich finde, dementsprechend relativ gleich gut. Vielleicht sogar leicht besser. Das könnte man mir jetzt auch vorhalten, dass ich das eigentlich auch anmoderiert habe. Aber ich würde sie rundum als in etwa gleich gut einschätzen.
Darf ich eine Sache zu Patrick Pfeiffer loswerden? Der ist ja durchaus Ex-Darmstädter. Der hat ja schon einige Jahre bei Darmstadt 98 gespielt.
Das ist richtig.
Ist dann zu Saison 23, 24 zum FC Augsburg gewechselt. Wurde in der Saison 24, 25, wenn ich das richtig sehe, zu Young Boys Bern verliehen. Dann zurück zum FC Augsburg. Wurde dann aber nach Magdeburg verliehen. Und ist jetzt bei Darmstadt. Er muss einfach wieder nach Hause kommen, der Junge. Sehr, sehr witzig, muss ich sagen. Aber von daher, das ist eine sehr gute Rückkommunikation. Aber bei mir ist halt einfach, ich glaube, bei mir ist einfach Kohfeldt das Problem, dass ich einfach nicht weiß, ja, welchen Kohfeldt kriegen wir denn jetzt mal über die Saison? Der, der Darmstadt übernommen hat und absoluten Running gelegt hat oder die Rückrunde unter Kohfeldt.
Die war gruselig.
Die war halt einfach nix. Also, das muss man einfach so ganz deutlich, die war einfach nix. Du hast, du hast es eben schon angesprochen, du hast in der Liedberg generell super interessanter Sturm, Liedberg, Hornby, Corridor und dann noch Bialek vorne drin von Wolfsburg gekommen. Aber ja, also es kann halt auch, ich glaube, meine Prognose zur Darmstadt, die Spiele werden uns, glaube ich, werden immer unterhaltsam sein.
Das ist ja auch ein Gewinn.
Wertfrei, das kann in beide Richtungen gehen für Darmstadt. Aber deshalb habe ich sie nämlich auch gleich bis vielleicht leicht besser als im Vorjahr. Wenn du da halt mal Konstanz rein kriegst, gibt es sicherlich auch mal das Potenzial, auch weiter oben anzuklopfen. Aber ja, Florian Kohfeldt bleibt für mich, weiß ich nicht, der könnte das Ehrenmitglied von den drei Fragezeichen werden. Aber auch nur, weil er ein ganz großes Fragezeichen für mich ist.
So, stark.
Justus, Peter, Bob und Florian.
Sehr schön. Mal gucken, für welche Abteilung er zuständig wäre. Aber dann kommen wir doch, wenn wir über Spektakel und Unterhaltung reden, müssen wir jetzt auch zur Aminia kommen. Erzähl doch mal, Eva, was ist denn da passiert?
Du, ich weiß es auch nicht und an der Stelle auch. Bitte entschuldigt meine Stimme. Ich habe sie gestern Abend im Stadion gelassen. Auch der Sprechmuskel ist ja durchaus ein Muskel, den man trainieren muss, wenn man so zwei Monate lang nicht trainiert hat. Weil, Surprise, sonst schrei ich nicht so viel in meiner Freizeit. Manchmal ist es dann doch durchaus etwas komisch. Aber ne, also Bielefeld kann das erste Spiel nach dem Ausstieg mit 5 zu 1 gegen von Thuner Düsseldorf gewinnen. Düsseldorf geht in der ersten Hälfte durchaus verdient in Führung. Nach einer gelb-roten Karte gegen Tim Oberdorf kann Bielefeld aber das Spiel schon in der ersten Halbzeit noch ausgleichen und dann in Halbzeit 2 komplett drehen und zu ihren Gunsten gestalten und 4 Tore schießen. Ja, und hinterher gab es auch noch 10 Minuten Nachspielzeit, wo ich glaube, Halbdeutschland sich immer noch fragt, wofür. Also bei allem Respekt für Verletzungspausen, VR-Checks und Co., das war doch ein bisschen lang. Ja, ich weiß nicht, Marc, vielleicht möchtest du einfach mal mit Düsseldorf tatsächlich reinstarten.
Kann ich damit tun.
Ich glaube, per se gibt es da einige Parallelen, die wir auch schon zu härter gesagt haben.
Ja, doch, durchaus. Also Düsseldorf schätze ich als in etwa gleich gut ein. Und das ist bei einer Mannschaft, die ja wirklich ein gehöriges Wort auch im Aufstiegskampf letztes Jahr geführt hat, ja erstmal was Gutes. Das liegt natürlich zum einen an Trainer Daniel Thun. Der ist jetzt wirklich schon lange da, seit 2022, würde man behaupten, nach Eichner wahrscheinlich der Dienstälteste in dieser Liga. Du weißt, was du mit ihm bekommst. Der Kader hat sich schon verändert, muss man sagen. Du hast auch mit dem Johanneson einen wirklich wichtigen Spieler verloren, aber auch interessante Spieler dazugewonnen. Das muss man auch sagen. Interessante Transferphase. Und wie ich finde, ein Spieler dazugewonnen, der jetzt auch gegen Bielefeld getroffen hat, Cedric Itten. Ich musste an einer anderen Podcaststelle mal nennen, wen ich als Torstützenkönig tippen würde. Und ich habe Cedric Itten gesagt, ich finde, der passt als Stürmertyp so krass in diese Liga. Und ich glaube, bei Düsseldorf wird sich sehr viel auf die Stürmertore konzentrieren. Und dann ist Cedric Itten dein Mann. Ansonsten ist das erstmal per se wirklich ein stabiler Kader mit vielen Unterschiedsspielern. Ich finde, dass Christian Rasmussen jetzt auch, trotz des Ergebnisses gegen Bielefeld, schon gezeigt hat, ja, mit dem wird zu rechnen sein, sowohl im Tempo als auch in der Technik. Also wie der einmal da Handwerker davon gelaufen ist, der sah doppelt so schnell aus, was ist da passiert? Egal. Vieles. Vieles ist passiert. Handwerker ist nicht passiert in dem Moment. Nee, aber du hast natürlich immer noch so Spieler wie Matthias Zimmermann, wie Florian Kastenmaier, die einfach diese Liga kennen, die ein Grundniveau haben. Dazu, wie gesagt, junge Spieler, die vielleicht explodieren können. Das ist in den letzten Jahren bei Düsseldorf eigentlich auch verlässlich passiert, wenn wir an Solis und Co. denken. Und deswegen wird Düsseldorf definitiv wieder eine Rolle im Aufschließkampf spielen. Und daran ändert, finde ich, auch dieses Spielnix, denn das hat seine ganz eigene Geschichte geschrieben, mit eigenartigen Schiedsrichterentscheidungen, mit Pech bei Gegentoren. Ich finde, du kannst an diesem Spiel überhaupt nicht ablesen, wie es um Düsseldorf bestellt ist und um Gottes Willen schon gar nicht, dass sie jetzt irgendwie einbrechen werden in der Saison. Ich würde das krass einklammern, dieses Spiel.
Ja, ich gehe da auf jeden Fall eigentlich komplett mit, was du gesagt hast. Also, es hat Rick Itten natürlich never forget, als Itten und Itter bei der Spielvereinigung viertgespielt haben.
Itten auf den Tisch.
Es war eine gute Zeit. Nein, also generell erwarte ich auch von Düsseldorf viel. Ich sehe sie auch da oben mit drin. Letzte Saison hat einfach hinten raus nicht gereicht, unter anderem eben auch. Und das ist mein Problem. Ich finde, sie haben immer wieder so Spiele, wo die Abwehr einfach nicht passt, wo sie individuelle Fehler hinten drin haben, wo die Zuordnungen nicht passen. Und da bleibe ich auch bei, dass das so eine Mini-Problem-Spendenstelle werden könnte. Nicht explizit am Spiel gestern gesehen, sondern einfach weil– also ich finde die Offensive gut besetzt, aber defensiv habe ich schon manchmal das Gefühl, dass es da nicht immer perfekt läuft. Du hast natürlich eine absolute Konstante mit Florian Kastenmaier da hinten drin. Da weißt du einfach, was du bekommst. Aber ich sehe da trotzdem– also ich sage dazu, sie sind für mich Ausstiegskandidat, nicht unter den ersten zwei. Sie müssen gegebenenfalls ihre Trauma noch mal überwinden in der Relegation. Wenigstens diesmal nicht gegen Bochum, könnte man eventuell sagen, das steht schon mal fest. Ja, aber per se bin ich halt auch fern davon, dass man einen Tun festgehalten hat. Ich mag das in diesem– kurz ein bisschen pathetisch– aber in diesem Fußballbusiness, wenn man eben so eine gewisse Konstanz hat und da eben auch weiter reingeht. Aber ja, also ich muss dazu sagen, ich finde, man hat gestern zum Teil nach Abpfiff, zumindest von Spielerseite, mir ein bisschen zu viele Ausreden gegeben. Tune hat das an der Pressekonferenz ganz anders gemacht. Übrigens sehr, also sehr gute Aussagen von ihm. Den merkt man einfach.
Generell, Daniel Tune, PKS sind eine Sonne.
Super.
Super sympathischer Kerl, super klarer Blick. Mega.
Ja, also, ja, ich finde halt, ich muss halt einfach sagen, man kann den Unterzahl verlieren, aber man muss überlegen, ob man den Unterzahl so verliert. Und man muss dazu sagen, wir haben schon über ein Spiel gesprochen, wo sich der die Mannschaft den Überzahl schwer getan hat. Wir sprechen gleich noch über ein anderes Spiel, wo schwer getan ein anderes Feedment ist. Aber ja, also da muss ich sagen, ja, du kannst dieses Spiel verlieren und sicherlich kann man auch alles diskutieren. Ich finde halt einfach ganz kurz dann nur meine Einschätzung zu, die gelb rote Karte von Timo Oberdorf, in jedem anderen Spiel würde ich sie nicht pfeifen. In dem Spiel, das was Patrick Alta über weite Strecken gefiffen hat, muss er sie fast geben, weil er hat halt ab der zweiten Minute Geld für jedes taktische Foul gegeben.
Das ist der erste Fehler, aber dann musst du eine Linie haben.
Und er hat ja am Ende, könnte man sogar sagen, hätte er, glaube ich, Jermin Siebert auch noch vom Platz stellen können und Co. Also er ist an der Linie einfach nicht treu geblieben. Und von daher verstehe ich auch den Unmut vieler Düsseldorf-Fans, versteht mich da nicht falsch. Aber ja, da muss man am Ende auch sagen, dafür, dass Timo Oberdorf durchaus noch ein paar Erfahrungen, also kein junger Spieler ist, der das erste Mal in der 2. Liga spielt, sondern das kennt, der Kapitän der Mannschaft ist, da erwarte ich von ihm tatsächlich auch in dem Moment einfach ein bisschen mehr Fingerspitzengefühl für die Situation, weil er weiß, wie es aussehen kann. Der Linien-Richtschuh steht direkt davor, der Schiedsrichter steht zwei Meter entfernt, dann bleibt er einfach weg und es passiert halt nichts. So in der gegnerischen Hälfte, glaube ich sogar. Also muss man an der Stelle selber wissen. Ja.
Und dann kommen wir zu Aminia. Ich fange da vielleicht mal an mit dem Blick von außen.
Gerne.
Das Ergebnis bestätigt ja einige, die sagen Aminia, Durchmarsch. Also Aminia entwickelt sich ja ein bisschen zum Belgien von WMs und WMs. So sehr Geheimfavorit, dass es schon gar kein Geheimfavorit mehr ist. Denn auch ich würde sagen, also ich gehe nicht so weit wie andere, die sagen, die spielen um den Aufstieg mit oder wären Top 6. Um Gottes willen, das glaube ich wirklich nicht. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich, dass Aminia eine sorgenfreie Saison spielen wird. Und das wäre als Aufsteiger doch überragend.
Es wäre so schön.
Es wäre so schön. Es wäre so schön. Das liegt daran natürlich, wie sie sich zum einen in der Liga, aber auch im Pokal logischerweise letztes Jahr präsentiert haben. Da zeigt sich eine Mannschaft, die eine spielerische Identität hat, die richtig Herz hat, die eine tolle Achse hat an Führungsspielern, die sich nicht verstecken in Druckphasen. Ich finde das krass. Ich finde, dass mit Kniat sehr gut passt. Wir wissen auch alle, die Kniat rausrufe. Da hat sich ein bisschen was getan in Wielefeld. Und dementsprechend glaube ich, dass diesen Verein gerade einen Duft des Positiven umweht. Und ich glaube, der verweht nicht so schnell in dieser Saison. Ich glaube, der wird sie ein Stück weit tragen. Und wird sie in jedem Spiel mindestens mal auf Augenhöhe spielen lassen. Klar, es werden ja noch Auftritte da sein, wo sie Lehrgeld zahlen werden. Es ist ja in Teilen auch ein junger Kader. Aber insgesamt ist das alles irrestabil. Und ich halte sie auch für eine Mannschaft, die absolut einen Tabellen-Mittelfeldplatz belegen können. Vielleicht sogar überraschend auf so was wie einen neuen Land, der in Köln drin. Aber viel höher, glaube ich, wird es dann nicht. Und dieses erste Spiel hat eben bewiesen, dass sie mithalten können. Wie gesagt, es war ein Freakspiel. Das wird jetzt nicht jedes Mal so laufen.
Klar, ja.
Aber auch die Transfers, spannend. Also, dass man dann Marvin Mehlum bekommen hat, das ist krass für einen Aufsteiger. Man hat einige junge Spieler dazu gewonnen. Klar, Louis Oppi zu verlieren, Marius Wöll zu verlieren. Aber immerhin darf er jetzt U23 bei Hannover spielen.
Ja, Star-Cos-Mann.
Aber ich würde auch behaupten, es wird jetzt nicht mehr spät zu krassen Abgängen kommen. Oder gibt es da Gerüchte, küchemäßig irgendwas, dass man sagt, nee, der Russo oder so, da könnte noch mal jemand zuschlagen. Wenn das nicht passiert, dann halte ich diese Mannschaft für absolut kassenhaltsfähig. Nicht nur das, sondern sie werden in meiner Welt auf einem Mittelfeldplatz landen und eine sorgenfreie Saison spielen.
Nee, also du hast sehr viel Richtiges gesagt. Also generell muss ich einfach sagen, dass das Wort Konstanz und Stabilität zu hören bei Minja Bielefeld tut mir sehr gut und ey, Freunde, ihr könnt euch endlich drauf freuen. Ich darf endlich legal über Bielefeld in diesem Podcast reden. Die habe ich sehr zurückgehalten bisher. Das muss man auch einfach sagen in dieser Folge. Das ist so. Nein, ich muss einfach sagen, ich habe tatsächlich bei Mitch Kniart schon lange gesagt, ich glaube, dass der, also er ist ja auch einer dieser Neulinge, also sowohl Mitch Kniart hat keinerlei Zweitliga-Erfahrung und bis auf Noah Sarin, Basé, Tim Hanferka und Mavi Melem hat auch niemand in diesem Kader Zweitliga-Erfahrung.
Kudofsky hat eine Hinrunde bei Münster gespielt, aber das kann man kaum zählen.
Niemand hat mehr, also andersrum formuliert, mehr als 30 Spieler haben nur drei Spieler in diesem Kader. Und das ist natürlich auch ein absolutes Risiko. Da ist einem bewusst, aber man muss einfach sagen, zum Beispiel Tim Hanfaker hat bei der Verpflichtung gesagt, er hat das Gefühl, er kommt in ein absolut funktionierendes Gefüge. Und das war für ihn hintenrum auch ein Ausschlag geben, was natürlich auch total für Michael Mutzen und mit Kniat spricht, was sie da geformt haben. Und das ist eben, bis auf Luis Oppi, gut Marius Wöhrl, eine Story ein bisschen kompliziert haben mit dieser Kaufoption, Rückkaufoption und jetzt dieses Hickhack, wo Hannover erst drei Millionen wollte und jetzt heißt es mehr. Und zweifel kann er doch für eine Million gehen. Mal schauen, was da jetzt noch kommt. Aber prinzipiell muss ich sagen, spricht halt dafür, dass auch Jonas Kerske den Vertrag verlängert hat und Stefano Russo hat seinen Vertrag verlängert. Also das sind, wenn auch alle Spiele, die kosten dann jetzt auch ein bisschen Kohle. Und ich meine, man muss einfach sagen, für Luis Oppi hinten raus, irgendwie die drei Millionen zu holen, das ist halt, also das muss auch Bielefelds Weg sein. Da bin ich der festen Überzeugung, Jugendspieler zu entwickeln. Du hast mit Daniel Richter einen aus der U19, der einfach unfassbar viel Potenzial zeigt. Da bin ich richtig gespannt. Und du hast jetzt eben auch, dass es wird vielleicht ganz interessant werden, weil du eben jetzt neu zu dieser Saison in der Oberliga Westfalen U23 oder in der zweiten Mannschaft wieder an Start bringen konntest. Das könnte auch durchaus ein Weg sein, um einigen Spielern trotzdem Spielzeit zu geben. Die U23 wird von dem ehemaligen Co-Trainer, also einem der Co-Trainer, mit Knien hat trainiert. Einer Draht, also. Genau. Und eben auch eine vielleicht, natürlich nicht einzig gleiche Spielidee, aber einfach die wissen, wie der andere funktioniert. Das könnte alles ein Vorteil sein. Ich muss einfach sagen, ich war komplett überrascht von diesem Spiel, weil man muss einfach sagen, es war eben auch in der Vorbereitung Co, es war kein Offensivfeuerwerk. Man hat im letzten Testspiel gegen Monaco, okay, es ist Monaco, aber gegen Monaco gesehen, da war, ja, Chancenverwertung war es nicht so, um jetzt halt fünf Tore zu erzielen. Also man muss diese Tore sich auch erstmal rausspielen. Mit Julian Kania hast du einen, der weiß ich nicht, der meistens immer noch als Stoker fungiert, was ich auch okay finde, das sehen auch andere anders. Aber der halt da ist und der kann, wir haben endlich einen Spieler, der Elfmeterschießen kann. Leute, die uns in der ersten Drittliga-Saison gesehen haben, wissen, ich glaube, da haben wir 75 Prozent der Elfmeter verschossen. Von daher, das sind alles so Punkte, und man muss einfach sagen, du hast mit Mael Corbos, einem Kapitän, der einen richtig schwierigen Start hatte, sich aber reingefunden hat ins Team und für mich gestern ein Spiel gemacht hat, also dem konntest du zwischendurch nicht ansehen, dass der noch nicht eine Minute 2. Liga gespielt hat. Und das fand ich schon sehr eindrücklich. Natürlich, es wird nicht immer so laufen. Das weiß, ich würde sagen, 95 Prozent in Bielefeld wissen das, aber es ist halt trotzdem eine Euphorie, gerade hinter diesem Verein, also für mich als Fan noch nie so existiert hast. Du hast 17.000 verkaufte Dauerkarten, du hast 27.000 Mitglieder, du bist innerhalb von– also es ist eine Mitgliederkampagne letzte Saison gestartet, zum 120-jährigen Jubiläum. Da stand man, glaube ich, bei 15.000 und wollte 19.005 erreichen zum Jubiläum. Wir sind bei 27.000 Mitgliedern in einem Jahr. Natürlich viel mit Pokal zu tun. Viele werden nach diesem Jahrablauf auch wieder aus ihrer Mitgliedschaft rausgehen. Ist okay, die wollten dann die Vorteile auch mitnehmen, die sie biegen, aber das spricht sehr viel für den Verein. Ich hoffe nur einfach, man bewährt Ruhe. Das ist mein letzter Satz dazu. Ich hoffe, man bewährt Ruhe. Ich freue mich auch, wenn es im Stadion ab und zu mal ein bisschen leerer wird. Das ist schon sehr anstrengend und auch sehr gruselig zum Teil. Aber per se, ich bin großer Fan von Mitch Kniart. Ich finde, er spielt Fußball, auf den wir uns, glaube ich, in der 2. Liga durchaus freuen können. Also auch in der Allgemeinheit, weil er durchaus gerade gegen den Ball sehr ansehnlichen Fußball spielen lässt.
Kniart nieder, Diaminja ist da. Ich muss sie machen.
Eva, komm. Ist okay.
Du wolltest eine Folge mit mir, du bekommst eine Folge mit mir.
Na ja, ist okay.
So, gehen wir weiter und gehen wir zu den Sonntagspartien. Und da hat Hannover 96 1 zu 0 gegen Kaiserslautern gewonnen. Das war in meinen Augen von Beginn an eine spielerisch klare Angelegenheit. Auch wenn Hannover zunächst die Effektivität, ruhig, fehlte, waren sie fußballerisch dennoch deutlich besser als Kaiserslautern. 96 kontrollierte die Begegnung. Der FCK wollte eigentlich nur kontern und konnte sich bei Kieper Krall bedanken, dass die Begegnung nicht schon viel früher entschieden war. Hannover behielt die Ruhe, blieb am Drücker und erzielte dann in der 74. Minute in Person von Joker, Asseco und Kili. Übrigens, Hertha Eingewächs. Da rede ich mal kurz über Hertha, den verdienten Siegstreffer.
Herz bricht.
Ja, es ist schon ein bisschen so. Einer der vielen Jungs von Hertha, die halt früh vom FC Bayern weggekauft wurden tatsächlich und dann weitergegangen sind. Hannover zeigt also schon früh, dass sie auf Kurs sind und Casas-Lautern muss, wie ich finde, spielerisch dringend noch einen Gang zulegen. Eva, wie hast du denn 96 eingeschätzt? Da sind ja einige richtig im Hype. Ich war noch ein bisschen vorsichtiger.
Ja, ich glaube, für mich war es einfach vor diesem Spiel– wir haben mal wieder das schöne Wort– Black Box. Ich muss dazu sagen, der Umbruch bei Hannover 96 war groß, neuer Trainer, zu 95 Prozent neuer Kader gefühlt. Und das kann natürlich immer in beide Richtungen gehen. Du kriegst so schnell hin, Automatismen reinzufügen, du kriegst so schnell hin, den Kader eben so zu formen, dass du Fußball auf hohem Niveau spielen kannst. Und da muss ich einfach sagen, wenn dieses erste Spiel indikativ sein könnte, dann hat das mit diesen Automatismen und der T-Shirt brutal gut funktioniert. Also ich glaube, das kann man schon relativ klar so sagen. Da hat sehr, sehr viel gepasst, da ist sehr, sehr viel zusammengelaufen. Du hast natürlich im Tor, glaube ich, die Neuerung, ehrlich gesagt, dass du da jetzt Neul drin hast, Thieler, der zum 1. FC Köln gewechselt ist. Von daher natürlich war ein Risiko für mich, da sind sie tatsächlich– für mich waren sie einfach Top-Aufstiegskandidat, weil ich einfach sagen muss, dieser Umbruch hat Sinn. Also weil ein Ding, was mir an Hannover letztes Jahr nicht gefallen hat, war einfach der Kader. Der hat nicht gestimmt, der hat nicht gepasst, der war für mich zu viel Rumgewürfle, was man ja vielleicht noch so nehmen könnte.
Ich fand den ja auch wirklich bieder.
Ja, genau. Also du hattest halt so das Gefühl, da hat man halt irgendwie nichts gegen Andreas Vogelsammer, aber einen Spieler geholt, der war mit Bielefeld gut. Entschuldigung. Aber hat dann halt bei Union und dann in England gespielt. Und ich glaube, der ist jetzt in der dritten Liga auch einiges besser einfach aufgehoben, um da halt eben nochmal seine Körperlichkeit auszuspielen. Und der hat nicht in diesen Anofer-Kader reingepasst. Dann hast du irgendwie Nilsen. Nilsen ist ein Spieler, den werde ich bis in alle Ewigkeit nicht verstehen. Vollständig Anofer 96. Das ist für mich auch eine Wundertüte. Aber generell muss man einfach sagen, mit Jakota, mit Bundu, mit Taibii. Das sind drei super interessante Spieler. Und man muss einfach sagen, es war ein bisschen unfair, als wir heute irgendwie von der Bank bringen konnten. Ja, im Prinzip auch den Sieg eingewechselt. Der Kader könnte beides ein Vorteil, die Kader breiter als auch ein absoluter Nachteil sein, weil er ist für mich noch zu groß.
Da haben auch einige Spieler jetzt in der U23 gespielt, ein Rogo und so weiter, die auch neu sind.
Man muss halt einfach sagen, wir fangen jetzt nicht die Diskussion an. Aber es ist natürlich ein absoluter Vorteil. Hannover 2 spielt jetzt nicht mehr die 2. Liga, sondern die 3. Liga, sondern die Regionalliga. Es ist natürlich ein Vorteil, die Spieler dahin zu schicken, die jetzt letzte, sondern die 3. Liga gespielt haben, jetzt Regionalliga, kann man nutzen für so eine Zwecke. Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, was wir dann noch von Hannover 96 sehen. Aber was sagst du denn?
Ich kann den Hype um Hannover definitiv verstehen. Bei mir war das Ding– also, wenn ich Christian Titz fände, offensichtlich muss man fast sein. Toller Fußball, mutiger Fußball, moderner Fußball, Fußball, der immer Spaß macht, toll, aber auch ein Fußball, der komplex ist. Und wo die Frage eben bestand, oder immer noch besteht, und das kann man nach einem Spiel eben nicht genau sagen, funktioniert das auf Anhieb. Eher beteuert, die Spieler sind insgesamt so früh gekommen, dass man schon sehr früh Automatismen trainieren konnte. Und wie gesagt, das Lagerland-Spiel ist ein Indikator für, trotzdem möchte ich das erst mal über ein paar Wochen sehen. Die Transfers auch natürlich super spannend. Das steht völlig außer Frage, aber wenn man sich die Transfers anguckt, davon hat gefühlt noch nie jemand 2. Bundesliga gespielt. Also da fällt ein Pichler raus, da fällt ein Neubauer raus, aber du hast so Namen wie Gita, Taibbi, Sterner, der es bei Kiel noch nicht gespielt hat, Kälmann, Bundu, Okon, Matsuda. Also Spieler, die nicht nur nicht die 2. Liga kennen, sondern Deutschland nicht kennen. Also das ist teilweise aus Japan, Südafrika, Polen, Frankreich zusammengeholt. Und das kann funktionieren, aber ist natürlich erst mal sehr wild. Das sind sehr unterschiedliche Typen, Kulturen, die da zusammenkommen. Und das kann auch kompliziert sein. Und dann können sich das Spieler vielleicht nicht wohlfühlen und Ähnliches. Also das birgt viele Fragezeichen. Und auch dahingehend wollte ich mich nicht festlegen, dass das auf Anhieb funktioniert. Und das dritte Argument ist, wer dann ja auch gegangen ist. Du hast Trisoldi verloren, du hast Zieler verloren, du hast Neumann verloren und Halstenberg. Das war eine zentrale Achse der letzten Saison. Ja, einer nicht sonderlich erfolgreichen Saison, aber trotzdem Spieler, die eher positiv hervorgestochen sind. Also es lag ja jetzt nicht an Halstenberg oder Trisoldi, das letztes Jahr nicht gelaufen ist. Und da seine komplette Führungsaktie zu verlieren und die vielleicht beste Innenverteidigung der Liga mit Halstenberg und Neumann, das fand ich, ich fand, das war nicht selbstredend, dass das jetzt besser funktionieren wird. Und wie gesagt, ein Spiel, das schon stabil aussah, die haben noch keine Bäume ausgerissen, aber es sieht stabil aus. Das kann Spaß machen und das kann auch dazu führen, dass Hannover am Ende aufsteigt. Das Potenzial sehe ich definitiv. Es würde mich aber auch nicht wundern, wenn da oft noch ein bisschen Sand im Getriebe ist, Spieler Formlöcher haben, erst mal ankommen müssen und am Ende wird Hannover 5. Aber mit der ganz klaren Perspektive, dass das dann im Jahr darauf klappt. Hannover ist spätestens in zwei Jahren der klare Aufstiegsfavorit. Das sehe ich. Dieses Jahr bin ich einfach noch ein bisschen, aufgrund der Faktoren, die ich genannt habe, ein bisschen gehemmter und deswegen sage ich, in etwa gleich gut. Aber wie gesagt, ich sehe total, dass das auch explodieren kann.
Mein größtes Fragezeichen ist, ob man die Chancen ein bisschen besser nutzt oder sich ein bisschen besser noch in Position führt. Torchancen. Also das war so der Knipser fehlt. Ja klar.
Also Kelmann hat es in Polen einigermaßen bewiesen, Pichla in Deutschland noch nicht so richtig, finde ich, dass er der Knipser ist. Ja und was ein bisschen doof war, nach meinen Tipps und so, haben sie dann auch noch das Yoko Taro geholt, der letztes Jahr so krass war bei Casas Lautern. Und da dachte ich, na toll, also weil der ist für sich genommen schon ein Faktor, warum es noch mal besser laufen könnte. Ja, dementsprechend, das ist schon alles sehr gut. Und mal gucken, ob es jetzt in einem Jahr schon so weit ist oder eher in zwei Jahren. Und dann sind wir bei Casas Lautern. Boah, also, boah, also, ich kann ja, soll ich mal vorweggehen?
Bitte, mach.
Ich hab sie jetzt leicht schlecht, also insgesamt als schlecht eingeschätzt.
Geh ich komplett mit.
Ich find's krass. Das sieht man dann ja auch in unseren All-Star-Teams. Sie sind mehrmals in den Aufstiegsringen dabei. Also ich glaube, wenn ich richtig gezählt habe, drei Leute tippen sie unter den ersten drei. Und das sehe ich nicht. Das sehe ich wirklich beileibe nicht. Ich finde es auch interessant, dass Thorsten Lieberknecht sehr offensiv davon spricht, dass man sagt, ja, keiner tippt uns da noch oben rein, aber wir haben den Traumaufstieg und das wollen wir dieses Jahr schaffen. Das sehe ich nicht. Das hängt mit mehreren Faktoren zusammen. Ich fand jetzt die Spiele von Lieberknecht, die ersten, die ich unter ihm gesehen habe, in Kassaslautern nicht überzeugend. Damit fängt es mal an. Sie haben mit Ragnar Aache einen der besten Spieler dieser Liga verloren und mit Karloč einen stillen Helden dieses Kaders. Ich fand ihn für das Mittelfeld schon echt wichtig. Sie haben dafür Spieler gewonnen. Semisahin, Kunze, Pretaljen, Emreli. Das sind Spieler, die definitiv gut in der 2. Liga sind. Aber für mich ist Kassaslautern, wenn ich das mit der letzten Saison vergleiche und auch mit dem Fußball von Markus Anfang vergleiche, das ist so viel biederer. Das muss nicht gleich unerfolgreicher sein. Aber insgesamt, wenn ich mir Trainer, Erwartungshalt und Kader angucke, irgendwie passt das für mich nicht zusammen. Und ich glaube, dass auch da– ich will Kassaslautern nicht unten reinreden, um Gottes willen– das ja völlig vermessen. Aber ich glaube, die werden am Ende vielleicht in der oberen Tabellenhefte dann vielleicht einen Tabellen-Mittelfeldplatz holen. Und dann sehe ich da auch nicht viel mehr. Aber wie siehst du es denn, Eva?
Nee, ich gehe da tatsächlich komplett mit. Also ich mag Thorsten Lieberknecht, der kann auch echt was schaffen. Aber dieser Kara passt für mich nicht. Also der passt einfach nicht. Und ehrlich gesagt, genau aus den Gründen, die du gerade aufgezählt hast. Ich habe sie auch von auf circa gleich bis schlechter getippt, was denke ich okay ist. Aber, ja, also klar, ein Spiel brauchst du es nicht dran zu messen. Das haben wir schon öfter gesagt. Aber da muss für mich gerade Offensiv viel mehr kommen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob sie viel mehr halt können. Ich habe halt so das Gefühl, das ist halt trotzdem in weiten Teilen ein Zweitliga-Kader, der vor zwei, drei Jahren um einiges besser performt hätte. Aber jetzt halt durchaus einige Spieler in sich, die halt schon ein bisschen unter ihrem Niveau kicken. Also im Sinne von oder einfach unter ihren Erwartungen zurückbleiben. Und ich glaube, das beschreibt dein Kaiserslaut am Ende des Tages für mich auch gut. Da steckt eine absolute Wucht hinter in diesem Verein. Du merkst, wenn es da mal läuft, auch im Schatten dieses Pokalfinals. Da kann echt viel passieren. Aber ich habe, also wilde These, aber ich habe bis heute auch immer noch das Gefühl, dass das Erreichen dieses Pokalfinals vielleicht auch manche Sichtweisen auf den Kader zu unsichtbar machen lassen, Probleme. Und die hat man für mich letzte Saison nicht behoben, was man natürlich auch sehen könnte an, wie die Saison gelaufen ist, mit dem Trainer wechselt. Und ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass man die zu dieser Saison stand jetzt, muss man ja dann doch immer sagen, weil wir eben Vortransferschluss aufnehmen. Passt es nicht, nee. Gut.
Und dann sind wir bei der nächsten Partie.
Ja, bei Magdeburg gegen Eintracht Braunschweig und Braunschweig. Die können direkt zu Beginn drei wichtige Punkte als einziges Auswärtsteam an diesem Spieltag mit nach Hause bringen. Ich glaube, für viele Leute durchaus überraschend, weil sie schon bei vielen Teams eben trotz der gewonnenen Relegation relativ weit unten sind. Man muss sagen, also absolute Energieleistung, vor allem trotz einer fast kompletten Halbzeit in Unterzahl. Magdeburg auf dem Papier vielleicht mit mehr Chancen und Spielanteilen. Aber ehrlich gesagt hat sich das viel zu harmlos nach vorne, vor allem in Überzahl hatte man das Gefühl, ja Braunschweig steht da als Bollwerk, aber sie haben kaum kreative Wege drum herum gefunden. Und am Ende macht es mir mit Aydin aus 32 Metern eben zum 1 zu 0. Absolut schönes Tor und man muss ja auch ganz ehrlich sagen, in Unterzahl musst du es auch mal genauso versuchen. Marc, lass uns doch vielleicht mal tatsächlich mit Magdeburg reinstarten. Was ist da deine Tendenz?
Ja, ich kann sagen, der Spieltag hat sie auf jeden Fall bestätigt, denn ich kann so vorweggreifen für mich in meiner Tabelle oder in meinen Top- und Flop-3 werden sie Tabellen 16. Ich habe gar kein gutes Gefühl bei Magdeburg diese Saison. Auch da der große Faktor Trainer. Du hast mit Christian Titz den Macher des Erfolgs der letzten Jahre verloren, der diesem Kader so viel Identität gegeben hat und diesen Kader auch permanent überperformen lassen hat. Du hast nie in der Saison auf diesen Kader erst geguckt und gedacht, naja, da müssen sie ja oben mitspielen. Das war die Arbeit von Christian Titz mit diesem Kader. Und nun ist es Markus Fiedler, zu dem ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel sagen kann. Auch der, der muss gute Arbeit in Stuttgart gemacht haben. Definitiv gilt als großes Trainer-Talent. Aber auch er ist ein absoluter Neuling in dieser Liga. Er ist 39 Jahre alt. Und das ist der eine Faktor, der aber nun mal der größte ist. Die Trainer-Personal, das sage ich dir verantwortlich immer wieder, ist die wichtigste im Verein. Und da hat man sich in meinen Augen erstmal, klar, verschlechtert. Das ist der eine Punkt. Und das andere ist die Transferphase. Ich finde, wenn schon der Trainer nicht überzeugen kann, dann muss es die Transferphase eigentlich tun. Und da erlebe ich so gar keine Wucht. Du hast mit Elhan Kouri einen wichtigen Spieler der letzten Saison verloren. Aber auch Livan Burcu, der jetzt bei Union wieder ist. Also zwei wirklich wichtige Spieler hast du verloren. Und du hast Spieler geholt wie Laurin Ulrich, Noa Pesc. Super junge Spieler, die die 2. Liga überhaupt nicht kennen und auch erstmal funktionieren müssen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob Magdeburg dieses Jahr ein so stabiles Gebilde sein wird, als dass diese Spieler funktionieren. Und der dritte Faktor für mich ist, die Spieler, die es in den letzten Jahren oft gerissen haben, die werden auch nicht jünger. Und ich finde, das sieht man auch an barisch-artig. Ich will jetzt noch nicht den Abgesang auf barisch-artig starten. Der ist 30 Jahre alt. Aber ich finde, wir sehen– Wir haben letzte Saison schon nicht mehr den selben barisch-artig erlebt, wie in der Saison davor. Und es würde mich wundern, wenn es passiert. Und ich frage mich, ob die Vertragsverlängerung von ihm nicht dahingehend sogar ein Indiz ist, dass man da nicht mehr so viel erwarten kann, wie in den Jahren zuvor, weil er auch weiß, ey, ich setze mich hier ins gemachte Netz. Ich weiß, ich bin hier der Unterschiedspieler. Ich darf hier kicken. Alles gut. Und dazu kommt– also für mich ist überhaupt nicht gesetzt, dass Martin K wieder 19 Mal knipst.
Wenn er denn bleibt, wenn ich gesagt habe. Da gab es ja auch genug Diskussionen jetzt.
Das ist ein weiterer Faktor, wenn er denn bleibt. Aber selbst wenn er bleibt, der hatte jetzt eine Super-Saison, Tore-mäßig. Aber für mich ist nicht entschieden, dass er das jetzt direkt wiederholen kann. Also so gut kenne ich ihn auf diesem Niveau noch nicht. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass auch da so ein bisschen wie bei Elbersberg sich einfach so eine Negativ-Spirale entwickeln könnte, aus der sie sich nicht so richtig befreien können. Und dann ist die Liga so eng, dass du Spiel um Spiel vielleicht knapp verlierst. Ich glaube nicht, dass die die werden nie null viel verlieren und du fragst dich, was ist denn mit denen los? Dafür ist die Axis zu scharfil, aber ich sehe die in so vielen direkten Duellen erstmal nicht als Favoriten. Und ich glaube, dass sich daraus eine Eigendynamik entwickeln könnte, die eklig wird.
Ja, da gehe ich tatsächlich mit. Es ist natürlich auch kein gutes Ohm, dass man das erste Heimspiel und eben als einziger Liga-Vertreter an diesem Spieltag eben direkt das Heimspiel wieder verliert. Und das war ja das große, große Problem in der letzten Saison, dass man das einen eben dran gehindert hat, ja wirklich auch potenziell aufzusteigen. Also eben weil man zu Hause die Punkte nicht holen konnte, auswärts das beste Team war, aber eben zu Hause die Punkte gelassen hat. Und so rein zu starten, muss ich auch einfach ganz– also ich mag den Standort Magdeburg, ich mag die Fans größtenteils, ich mag, was die mitbringen in die Liga generell. Ich finde, also das soll auch nicht zu pathetisch klingen, aber ich finde generell schön, wenn wir eben auch mehr, ja, Aufteilung haben an Vereinen in der Liga. Also nicht, also du hast ja jetzt im Prinzip eigentlich so ein bisschen die A2-Liga, du fährst ja immer die A2 lang und hast irgendwie– Die Elf-Freunde jetzt auch einen schönen Artikel, ja. Genau, Shoutout an Luis Richter. Du fährst ja quasi einmal die Linie durch. Ich mag das eigentlich, wenn du so ein bisschen durchmischter hast und irgendwie aus allen Bundesländern ein bisschen und eben dann eben auch aus dem Osten halt ein paar mehr Vereine. Bin ich per se erstmal Fan von, muss ich dazu sagen. Aber man muss halt einfach sagen, ich gehe da eben mit. Das wird nicht, das wird richtig schwierig. Für mich sind sie kein Absteiger. Das liegt aber weniger an ihnen und mehr als an den Vereinen, die ich unter ihnen sehe und ja. Also ich hatte auch das Gefühl, schon in diesem ersten Spiel war sehr, sehr viel Frustration zum Teil dabei und Markus Fiedler ist so. Ich habe ja einfach immer den Vorteil, dass ich dieses Team gesehen habe, Stuttgart 2. Aber man muss halt auch einfach sagen, es ist einfach was komplett anderes, mit einer Zweitvertretung in der dritten Liga zu spielen, als mit einer Mannschaft, mit so viel Tradition, mit durchaus auch Fans, die sich wünschen, irgendwie mal doch irgendwann ein paar Bundesliga zu spielen. Ja, das da, also ja, sehe ich nicht. Punkt.
Dann kommen wir zu einem anderen Zweitliganeuling. Oder wolltest du noch einen abschließenden Satz sagen zu Magdeburg?
Nee, ich wollte tatsächlich rüber wechseln zu Eintracht Braunschweig.
Dann kommen wir zu einem weiteren Liganeuling, nämlich Heiner Backhaus von Alemannia Aachen mit viel Getöse. Aber das ist ein eigenes Thema. Nach Braunschweig gekommen, 43 Jahre alt. Und er hat jetzt dieses Duell der Trainerneulinge gewonnen. Und ja, also ich habe Braunschweig als In-Etwa-Gleichgut eingeschätzt und ich habe sie nicht auf einen direkten Abstiegsplatz oder auch auf Platz 16 getippt. Ich glaube, die hieven sich tatsächlich dieses Jahr. Also bei Braunschweig geht es für mich dieses Jahr auch nur um Platz 15, 14, 13. Aber ich glaube, dass die es packen könnten, weil ich gut finde, also ich finde, dass sowohl auf der Trainerposition als auch bei den Transfers, das wirkt wie eine Frischzellenkur. Also sie haben sich von vielen Altlasten getrennt. Dazu zählt definitiv nicht Rayan Philipp, der Faktor war, dass also sein Abgang ist der Faktor für mich, warum ich sage, sie sind nicht besser als letztes Jahr, sondern sind vergleichlich gut, weil das musst du erst mal verkraften, so ein Abgang, das war der Unterschiedspieler für Braunschweig. Aber sie haben, wie ich finde, eine gute Transferperiode bisher hingelegt. Also du holst mit Ron-Torben Hoffmann den Toyota Fest, der letztes Jahr mit dafür gesorgt hat, dass du in der Liga geblieben bist, hast diese Personale also mal frühzeitig geklärt. Dasselbe mit Lino Tempelmann, der jetzt fest verpflichtet wurde und den Schalke 3er-Pack macht dann eben mehr mit einliegen, der definitiv der Spieler des Spiels war gegen Magdeburg. Irre viel geleistet in dem Spiel und auch das Tor geschossen. Ich finde, für Braunschweig ist das ein mehr zu lieder Rechtsverteidiger oder ein rechter Schienenspieler in dem Fall. Robin Heuser, ich habe nicht verstanden, warum der nicht in Karlsruhe funktioniert hat, weil ich den bei Wiesbaden herausragend gut fand. Und ich glaube, dass der bei Braunschweig, wenn er da absolut gesetzt ist, echt super gut sein kann. Ja, und auch Jadim Schi, der passt an sich als Philipp Ersatz, weil der ist super schnell und spielerisch gut. Also das, was Philipp ja auch ausmacht, das hat Jadim Schi drin. Aber natürlich junger Spieler, noch nicht lange in Deutschland. Das muss erstmal funktionieren. Aber das Potenzial sehe ich so. Und deswegen finde ich, die Spieler, sie haben junge Spieler geholt, die mal ein bisschen hungriger sein könnten. Sie haben mit Baccarus einen Trainer, das hat man in diesem Spiel gesehen, der erfindet den Fußball nicht neu. Das ist kämpfen, kreisen, kämpfen, beißen, kratzen. Aber finde ich irgendwie den Tick mutiger, den Tick offensiver, als es vielleicht unter vorherigen Trainern der Fall war. Und ich glaube, sie werden einfach nochmal unangenehmer sein, als vielleicht andere Braunschweigermannschaften der Vorjahre. Und ich glaube, dass das ein paar Prozentpunkte ausmachen könnte. Das ist immer noch kein guter Kader im Zweitliga-Vergleich. Und deswegen bleibe ich dabei, die werden um Platz 15 rum mitspielen. Aber ich glaube, dass sie vielleicht dieses Jahr ein etwas besseres Momentum entwickeln könnten. Und das hat dieses erste Spiel für mich unterstrichen. Sie könnten etwas mutiger agieren als in der Vergangenheit. Und das braucht Braunschweig, weil dieses Herummeandern in den letzten Jahren, das nervt selbst mich von außen, wo ich denke, was wollt ihr denn sein? Warum hieft ihr euch von Jahr zu Jahr und habt keine Vision? Das fand ich jedes Jahr anstrengend. Da wird mir, glaube ich, Anna Lautenbach absolut zustimmen. Und ich habe jetzt in diesem Sommer mal das Gefühl gehabt, ach Mensch, man denkt ja über ein Jahr hinaus, was Trainer und Kader angeht. Und das stimmt mich leicht positiv.
Ja, da gehe ich auf jeden Fall mit. Also für mich, ja, ich habe sie auch jetzt ungefähr gleich bis leicht besser. Ist ja auch nicht sonderlich schwierig, ehrlich gesagt. Als in der Vorsaison bei Heiner Backhaus bin ich mir nicht vollständig sicher. Also auch da, er hat ein Jahr dritte Liga als Trainer verantwortet, bevor für ihn jetzt eben auch der Sprung in die 2. Liga anstand. Ich glaube, er ist eben genau, was du gesagt hast, so jemand für die Intensität. Und da muss man einfach sagen, hat Braunschweig vieles auf den Platz gebracht, was man eben durchaus vermisst hat, einfach was einfach gefehlt hat in der letzten Saison. Gut, man muss es nicht direkt so übertreiben wie Elas, der da vollkommen zurecht mit Rot vorm Platz fliegt. Also da hat gar nichts gepasst vom Timing her. Aber man muss einfach sagen, ne, passt. Und man muss ja auch einfach sagen, du hast eben gesagt, Altlasten, ne. Und wenn man mal guckt, keiner dieser Altlasten, gewissenteils, also klar, Ryan Philipp ist halt zum Heiß-Vor-Gegangenen, ist keine Altlast. Der Rest, der hat halt auch noch keinen neuen Verein, ne. Und das ist halt, ohne denen da zu nahe treten zu wollen. Aber ich finde es auch wirklich, also sich von Ermin Bicacic zu trennen, wird kein einfacher Schritt gewesen sein. Ich glaube, das muss man auch sagen. Einfach, wenn man weiß, okay, der hat hier halt einfach so ein Stück Identität wieder in den Verein gebracht. Aber man musste halt einfach sagen, ne, aber wir müssen jetzt den Cut setzen. Und da kann halt so jemand einfach auf Jeroen Torben, Hoffmann, Lino Tempelmann, die eben, ja gerade Hoffmann, dieser komische Stint da mit Schalke dann schon ausgeliehen und jetzt eben wieder festgeholt. Die können halt für neue Identifikationen sorgen. Ich muss sagen, ganz dringend, ich muss sagen, ich vergesse permanent Sebastian Polter. Ich vergesse einfach, dass der noch Fußball spielt. Da bin ich auch ganz ehrlich.
Ich glaube, das vergisst er manchmal auch.
Aber ja, also ich bin auch sehr gespannt, was wir sehen. Aber ich muss halt auch wirklich sagen, ich will jetzt auch eine Entwicklung sehen. Ich möchte auch von Braunschweig jetzt eine Entwicklung sehen. Und ich glaube, da sprechen wir eben auch für Anna und da sprechen wir auch für alle Eintracht-Fans, weil es ist einfach irgendwann anstrengend, Jahr für Jahr gegen den Abstieg zu spielen. Und du das Gefühl hast, wir wissen vom ersten Spieltag, es wird wieder dahin gehen. Und wir wissen auch, das wird in der Winterpause nicht besser sein. Und ich glaube schon, dass sie in dieser Saison um einiges früher den Klassenerhalt festmachen könnten. Aber ich bin da mal sehr, sehr gespannt, was wir hinten raus sehen. Weil man muss auch sagen, es ist halt auch wieder ein Risiko mit Heiner Backhaus. Aber da sind sie halt im Vorteil, sie sind nicht alleine damit.
Ja, und immerhin ist da mal wieder was Lebendiges. Ich weiß leider nicht mehr, welcher Spieler das war, der eine ziemliche Generalkritik nach der Saison dargelassen hat, was auch Trainingsbedingungen und so angeht und sagt, dieser Verein ist eingestaubt. Das muss jetzt einfach mal aufgelockert werden. Dafür ist Heiner Backhaus, glaube ich, der Richtige. Ich weiß nicht, ob der sich über viele Jahre trägt. Ich glaube, das ist vielleicht eine ganz bewusste Entscheidung, von Jahr zu Jahr zu einem anderen Verein zu hoppen. Aber für den ersten Moment ist der, glaube ich, gar nicht so schlecht. So, und dann sind wir bei der allerletzten Partie dieses Spieltags. Na Mensch, haben wir es doch mal geschafft.
Lohnt unser anderthalb Stunden Projekt so lang richtig gut gehalten. Wer guck oder zauert wach?
Naja, ach, die Leute freuen sich. Erste Sendung, viel Futter ist doch schön. Und dann sind wir nämlich bei Fyrth und Dresden. Ja, auch ein flippiges Duell. Fyrth gewinnt am Ende 3 zu 2. Ja, schon flippig.
Er benutzt dieses Wort unter 50.
Büromonis benutzen das Wort. Wir müssen die abholen. Wir müssen unsere, wir müssen die Reichweite auch in gewisse Zielgruppen führen. Fyrth gewinnt hier ja auf jeden Fall 3 zu 2 gegen Dresden. Und das war wirklich eine wilde Partie. Das vielleicht wildeste Duell des ersten Spieltags. Fyrth ging nach nur 20 Sekunden in den Führungen. Futtkoi ist der Torschütze. Nach neun Minuten legt man das 2 zu 0 nach. Dynamo antwortet direkt mit einem 2 zu 1 durch Herferner. Und dann liegt das Momentum schon bei Dresden. Aber es kamen erst mal keine Tore. Und nach dem Pausen geht es erst mal direkt so weiter. Denn direkt wieder Fyrth, direkt wieder schnell und direkt wieder Futtkoi. In 51 Minuten das 3 zu 1. Da lässt er gleich drei D-Sner-Defensivspieler stehen, dupiert die Regel recht. Und auch dann, Dresden kommt wieder, baut sich Momentum auf, will und kommt auch mit dem 3 zu 2 durch Kammerknecht auch noch mal ran. Aber trotz all des Drückens kommt am Ende kein 3 zu 3 raus. Und so holt Fyrth tatsächlich den ersten Sieg der Saison. Und das ist ein Signal, denn Fyrth ist, glaube ich, auch eine Black Box. In diesem Riesenumbruch und mit diesem wirklich schlimmen letzten Jahr. Und ja, was machen wir denn jetzt erst mal aus Dresden, aus dem Spiel, Eva?
Boah, gute Frage. Also auch da bin ich ja relativ nah dran gewesen. Ich muss einfach sagen, es ist vielleicht nicht ganz fair, weil es ist wirklich sehr interessant. In unserem Old-State-Team hat niemand Bielefeld als Absteiger getippt, aber durchaus viele Dresden.
Unter anderem ich, ich bekenne mich schuldig.
Ja, ich mich tatsächlich auch, was überhaupt nichts gegen Dresden ist. Aber ja, sie haben super interessante Spieler. Also ich glaube gerade Konrad Fahbar, dem man eben, es könnte ein absoluter Unterschiedspieler sein.
Aber er jetzt im ersten Spiel defensiv wirklich schlimm war. Beide Tore fallen über seine Seite.
Genau, das ist nämlich das Ding an Dynamo Dresden. So gut sie in der Offensive sind, desto Probleme haben sie durchaus in der Defensive. Das hat sich auch zum Teil in der dritten Liga durchgezogen. Man muss sagen, diese letzte Drittligasaison war Vogelwild. Ich glaube auch, dass das zum Teil noch nachgehangen hat bei Dynamo-Spielern, dass man eben diese Meisterschaft dann eben noch vergeben hat. Und ich glaube also, für mich ist Dresden eine Mannschaft, die ganz, ganz viel durch Emotionalität lebt. Und das kann in beide Richtungen laufen. Also das kann einfach– und das hast du bis zu weiten Strecken eben gesehen in diesem Spiel, diese beiden Extreme zu– oh, wir kriegen direkt einen Dämpfer, wir kommen überhaupt gar nichts ins Spiel bis zu– aber wenn wir aber an Hoffnung schnuppern, dann sind wir auch da, und dann können wir den Gegner auch unter Druck setzen. Das hast du an Dresden halt diese Breite. Ich weiß nicht so ganz– also ich weiß schon, woher das, glaube ich, kommt, dass viele sie als Absteiger sehen, weil man einfach weniger von ihnen gesehen hat, als von Bielefeld, vor allem im direkten Vergleich halt mit Teams aus der Bundesliga und mit der 2. Liga. Das ist einfach so, das ist sicherlich nicht auch ganz fair. Aber ich glaube, also du hast einen Christoph Daferner, jemand, der gefühlt wirklich nur bei Dynamo Dresden funktioniert, nirgendwo anders, weder bei Nürnberg noch bei Düsseldorf, was natürlich auch für Dynamo spricht. Aber ich sehe da einfach Probleme und diese Probleme hast du einfach im Spiel gegen Fürth gesehen. Also, dass man eben sich diese– und ich meine, also wir werden gleich noch über Fürth sprechen– sprechen per se über eine Mannschaft, von der viele auch denken, dass das für die richtig schwierig werden könnte. Und ich bin mal gespannt, wenn Vincent Vermeid tatsächlich nach Dresden wechseln könnte das nochmal einen anderen Schwung reinbringen. Aber ich glaube, es ist ja schon so bei Dresden, da ist ein bisschen mehr Zweitliga-Erfahrung drin. Die Mannschaft ist per se, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen älter als die von Bielefeld.
Ich würde älter unterschreiben, aber nicht Zweitliga-Erfahrer. Ich finde, dass in der Mannschaft gibt es wenig Zweitliga-Erfahrungen. Rossi Pall, der hat sie bei Rostock ein bisschen gesammelt und auch Nils Fröhling bei Rostock. Und ansonsten wird es dünn, also da ferner. Gut, aber viel sind tatsächlich Spieler, die…
Stefan Kutschke, der hat doch auch schon bei Dresden gespielt, als sie die 2. Liga gespielt haben, oder?
Ja, aber war das so viel Zweitliga-Erfahrung?
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau.
Ich gucke jetzt live nach. Wir fact-checken, der Mann hat 124 Zweitliga-Spiele. Okay, das letzte Mal, 2022, ist ein bisschen her. Naja, aber ich finde, ich würde nicht unbedingt unterschreiben, dass das eine Zweitliga-erfahrene Truppe ist.
Nee, nicht erfahren, erfahren näher als gezwungen.
Okay, dann sind wir auf einer Seite. Ja, also ich habe Dresden tatsächlich als direkten Absteiger getippt. Das liegt daran, dass mich die Transferphase bislang überhaupt nicht überzeugt. Ich finde, sie haben wenig an Qualität und wenig an Zweitliga-Erfahrung dazugewonnen. Wie gesagt, Doppelpack aus Rostock mit Rossi Pall und Fröhling, aber die sind auch nicht ohne Grund einmal auch sehr klarklangungsabgestiegen mit Rostock. Gut, sie haben keine Spieler aus dem Aufstiegserfolgskader verloren, außer, das ist wichtig, Jonas Sterner. Der war letzte Saison mit der beste Rechtsverteidiger der dritten Liga. Der ist jetzt auch zu fest zu Hannover gewechselt, war von Kiel ausgeliehen und dafür ist jetzt eben Faber gekommen. Mal sehen, ob er das ersetzen kann. Ich habe das Gefühl, so was ich mir auch angelesen habe und so, dass Dresden letzte Saison sehr über eine sehr wuchtige, dominant Spielweise reingekommen ist, die aber auch ein bisschen– es mag vielleicht sehr wertenklingen– sehr stumpf daher kam. Also man hat halt einfach Vollgas-Fußball gespielt, permanent. Und ich weiß nicht, ob man die individuelle Qualität jetzt in Zweitländer vergleicht hat, um seine Gegner gleich zu erdrücken. Jetzt gegen Fürth hat man Druck entwinkeln können, aber das liegt vielleicht auch einfach an einer Fürther-Mannschaft, die neu zusammengewürfelt ist und letzte Saison auch den Abschied gespielt hat und vielleicht daher noch nicht so gefestigt daherkam und das mit sich machen lässt, wenn sie dann führt. Aber ich habe erhebliche Zweifel daran, dass diese Spielweise funktioniert wird. Man hat sehr viel Vertrauen im Trainer Thomas Stamm, hat nach Vorsaison statt den Vertrag verlängert. Ruhe dahingehend bringt sicherlich was, aber du hast es schon gesagt, sehr imbezügliches Umfeld. Lass die mal die ersten 6, 7 Spiele verlieren. Ich glaube, dann wird es unruhig in Dresden. Die haben ohnehin einen leichten Knacks weg, weil sie seit Jahren eine Fahrstuhlmannschaft sind. Sie kennen das jetzt auch nicht, dass man dann vielleicht ein paar Spiele verliert und trotzdem in der Liga bleiben kann. Das war zuletzt eher kein gutes Umfeld, wenn das so angefangen hat. Diese euphoriehende Zusammenhalt, die können natürlich auch, ähnlich wie bei Bielefeld, auch für neue Höhen sorgen, dass man dann mit dieser Heimwucht vor allem Spiele gewinnt, die man eigentlich sonst nicht gewinnen würde. Aber ich gucke ganz neutral, berechnend auf diesen Kader und sage, das ist vielleicht der schlechteste Kader, vielleicht der schlechteste, das ist hart, aber es ist einer der schlechtesten Kader, individuell gesehen, in dieser Liga, wie ich finde. Und die können mich alle gerne überraschen. Und Dresden ist ein weiteres Essert in dieser Liga, ein weiterer totaler Zugewinn. Wäre schön, wenn die drin bleiben. Aber ich stand jetzt ein bisschen schwer, vor allem, wie du sagst, defensiv. Denn das war gegen Fürth gruselig defensiv.
Ja, das verstehe ich total. Und natürlich ein großes Fragezeichen, auch hinter Thomas Stamm. Also ich mag ihn als Trainer. Ich finde eigentlich, also nach Markus Anfang, ich war mir nicht sicher, wie er es schafft bei Dynamo Dresden. Also es war ja auch letzte Saison erst. Also erst seine erste Saison als Dynamo-Coach. Das hätte absolut in beide Wege für mich gehen können, weil du eben halt mit jemandem wie Stefan Kutschke halt jemand im Kader hast, der glaube ich durchaus sehr, sehr viel zu sagen hat. Obwohl er nicht mehr viel Spielzeit hat. Und sowohl ein Vorteil als auch ein Nachteil sein kann in diesem Team. Aber man muss halt auch sagen, also Stammtrainerkarriere ist nicht kurz, aber halt im Profifußball ist er kurz. Also er war eben lange Freiburg und 19 Trainer, dann war er drei Jahre lang Trainer von Freiburgs zweiter Mannschaft. Und jetzt eben dann für Dynamo Dresden, also auch der Sprung zu Dresden, war natürlich ein unglaublich großer, ehrlich gesagt ähnlich wie halt bei Kniet. Auch Kniet hat halt den Vorteil, dass er ein Jahr mehr unter Aminia mitgemacht hat und eben mit Aminia auch diesen Abstiegskampf im ersten Jahr mitgemacht hat. Und ich glaube, das ist, glaube ich, was bei vielen Bielefeld-Fans halt so im Hinterkopf ist und vielleicht auch bei anderen. Von daher, ja, das ist nur mein Gedanke noch dazu. Aber generell, ja, also ich glaube einfach, die Art und Weise, wie Dresden zum Ende der Saison und halt auch immer in der dritten Liga davor zum Ende der Saison agiert hat, dass sie es eben zweimal hintereinander verpasst haben, auch mit dem Ausstieg. Das sind halt alles so Sachen, die werden auch eben bei den Fans im Hinterkopf sein, Entschuldigung. Und da bin ich daher auch, ja, ich bin gespannt. Also ich meine, ich muss auch da sagen, prinzipiell können die auch noch ein Jahr in der Zwei-Liga spielen. Also so ist es nicht. Weil ich glaube, ein erneuter Abstieg wird halt auch richtig wehtun.
Du merkst aber, ich finde, ich dem Kader einfach an, die waren drei Jahre weg. Und ich finde, das merkst du dem Kader so langsam an. Es fehlen so Unterschiedsspiele auf Zweitliganiveau, wie ich finde.
Ja, da sind wir da mal, glaube ich, ziemlich gespannt. Und ich würde sagen, Marc, damit beenden wir unsere… Nein, nein, nein, nein, nur die Vorschau. Oder habe ich erführt?
Der erste Eklat dieser Rasenfunkstaffel, da wollte ich einfach fürz kippen.
Oh Gott, ist das unangenehm. Entschuldigung.
Ach, passiert.
Ich muss da zu meiner Verteidigung sagen, Dresden steht bei mir als letzte Stelle. Und deshalb habe ich sie jetzt einfach übersprungen. Entschuldigung, Marc, bitte.
Sehr schön.
So, wir holen einfach Michi Fischer in vielleicht die nächste Sendung. Kann er das ausgleichen. Also, hört. So, die letzte Black Box dieser Folge. Massiven Umbruch gehabt. Also, Gefühl 20 Spieler rein, 20 Spieler raus.
Der SV Sandhausen-Weg.
So ein bisschen, ja. Und mit Thomas Kleiner auch nach wie vor ja ein Unerf- Ich bin ein sehr gut verahrenden Coach, zumindest auf der Chef-Trainer-Position, der letzte Saison ja auch nur noch quasi, also sie in der Liga gehalten hat, fair enough, aber jetzt keine ganze Saison moderiert halt als Stammtrainer. Also auch da finde ich immer noch ein neues Gesicht ist. Dementsprechend einfach sehr viele Faktoren. Ich finde einige Dinge des Kaderumbruchs gut. Also ich finde, dass sie mit Aaron Keller einen super spannenden Spieler dazu gewonnen haben. Olesen, Dehm, Ziereis, das sind alles für mich erst mal Spieler, die auf zweitiger Niveau funktionieren sollten. Ich bin mir recht sicher, dass die Verantwortlichen viele Lehren aus der letzten Saison gezogen haben. Fürth halte ich auch insgesamt für besser als im Vorjahr. Und auch da geht das Schalke-Argument. Es kann auch wirklich nicht mehr schlechter werden. Das war wirklich eine so miese Saison. Das kann man kaum in Worte fassen. Das hat zum Bruch zwischen Mannschaft und Fans geführt. Das ist immer das schlimmste Signal, was es geben kann. Sie hätten letztes Jahr ein verdienter Absteiger sein können. Sie sind es nicht gewesen aufgrund der Konkurrenz. Ich glaube, das war vielleicht der Warnschuss, den sie gebraucht haben. Bei Fyrt sehe ich nicht mehr als Platz 12 in diesem Jahr. Das sage ich auch. Für mich geht es nicht darum, dass sie jetzt irgendwie durchrasieren, um Gottes willen. Aber ich finde den Kader vielleicht auch ausgewogener als im Vorjahr. Sie haben sich vielleicht mit Leuten wie Felix Hiegel auch vielleicht ein paar ganz gute Charaktere in die Mannschaft geholt, die mehr Verantwortung nehmen wollen. Sie haben jetzt mit Bo Wink auch einen erfahrenen Kader im Kasten. Vielleicht tut das auch mal gut. Neu spielt er jetzt in Hannover, passt vielleicht auch besser zum Stil von Titz. Deswegen finde ich den Kader insgesamt ein bisschen ausgewogener. Ich finde ihn immer noch nicht gut. Deswegen glaube ich, dass sie im letzten Tabellendrittel landen werden. Aber ich glaube, dass sie vielleicht nicht ganz so stark reingezogen werden in den Abschiedskampf wie im letzten Jahr. Und das wäre doch schon ein Erfolg, nachdem es letztes Jahr wirklich schlimm war. Und damit bin ich auch fertig mit Fird.
Ich ergänze einmal kurz dazu. Drei bei uns aus dem Oldster-Team haben sie als Absteiger tatsächlich getippt in dieser Saison. Also auch da zumindest ein Viertel ist nicht vollkommen überzeugt.
Es tut mir leid.
Ich werde tatsächlich per se mitgehen von dem, was du gesagt hast. Also ich glaube, da gab es absolut notwendige Trennungen auch. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich sage jetzt etwas, was, glaube ich, durchaus kontrovers sein könnte. Ich glaube, man muss sich langsam aber sicher immer mal von Brandy Miriam-Gotha trennen.
Nein! Hergotha!
Weil, und ich glaube, das ist halt, auf denen setzt man relativ viel und er bringt halt auch immer noch seine Leistung. Ich hatte aber zuletzt auch immer das Gefühl, dass man sich ein bisschen zu sehr an Hergotha als Stütze in diesem Kader ausgeruht hat. Ich glaube, da gab es andere Vereine auch, wo man eben gesagt hat, der ist ja da und dann basteln wir drum herum. Ich glaube, diese Saison kann er das noch gut machen. Ich glaube aber, dass du tatsächlich irgendwann mal nach dieser Saison vielleicht auch sagen müsstest. Ich meine, dann ist der Mann auch 33, wenn ich das richtig rechne. Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob man dann vielleicht mal sagen muss, nö. Also prinzipiell glaube ich, ja, es gibt definitiv Besserungen im Kader, leichte Verbesserungen, klar, viele Verletzungen, auch gerade jetzt noch vor Saisonstart. Ja, also ich glaube, ich stand jetzt auch in Keller verletzt, Sascha Banzé verletzt, Lukas Reich und Mark Ion. Genau, Mark Ion, eigentlich auch sehr interessant, weil der ja auch mal für mich mal so ein absolutes Talent da auf der linken Verteidigerposition galt.
Ja, der hatte echt eine gute Zeit mal in Hoffenheim und dann kam irgendwie nichts mehr.
Genau, also für mich eigentlich sehr interessanter Spieler, aber generell, also ich glaube, es ist nicht schlecht, da übrigens in Verteidiger Luca Itta, wobei wir wieder bei Itta und Ittin wären.
Der war letzte Saison vielleicht noch einer der Lichtblicker tatsächlich.
Ja, auch der natürlich verletzt, also Verletztenliste ist relativ lang. Aber ja, ich bin auch mal gespannt. Ich glaube, ich habe, wie gesagt, leicht besser aus den gleichen Gründen, wie du gesagt hast, aber so vollständig überzeugend. Und ich meine, ja, da lief vieles für sie heute im Spiel. Das war offensiv gut, aber halt auch defensiv Vogelwelt. Also ich habe nach zehn Minuten gedacht, gut, also es können auch beide Mannschaften einfach ohne Defensive spielen. Dann wird das ein unterhaltsames Spiel, aber auch ein sehr anstrengendes Spiel.
Vielleicht hilft es der Mentalität aber dann auch oder der mentalen Komponente, wenn man so ein Spiel über die Zeit bringt.
Voll, voll. Aber man muss natürlich auch, also ohne jetzt Dynamo Dresden auch zu nahe zu treten. Aber es war halt auch ein Spiel gegen den Aussteiger. Es könnte, also lass mich kurz einmal nachgucken, gegen wen es jetzt als nächstes geht. King Eintracht Braunschweig.
Das wird interessant, weil wenn sie das Spiel auch gewinnen sollten, sage ich jetzt mal, dann hätten sie schon zwei Spiele gegen direkte Konkurrenten im Abschiedskampf. Und ich glaube, darum geht es eben für Fürth besiegt. Das wäre schon ein starker Start.
Genau. Und dann halt nach dem DFB-Pokal Holstein-Kiel, Magdeburg. Also nach unserer Regelung drei Vereine, die wir eben da unten mit rein sortieren. Von daher bin ich da auch sehr, sehr gespannt drauf, was wir davon sehen. Aber Marc darf ich jetzt sagen, wir sind am Ende der Saison-Prognosen, bis auf einen kleinen Fakt angekommen. Denn Marc und ich, wir haben so viel über unsere Tabellentipps diskutiert. Und wir wollen jetzt natürlich einmal nochmal richtig hören, was sind unsere ersten drei, was unsere letzten drei. Ganz kurz noch den Rest. Wir zählen jetzt nicht alle Tipps des restlichen All-Star-Teams aus. Da, wie gesagt, schaut doch bitte bei den sozialen Kanälen vorbei und im Forum, da werdet ihr das finden. Aber Marc, wer steigt für dich auf? Wer steigt ab?
Ja, wie gesagt, nach dem ersten Spieltag sieht das nicht so gut aus.
Heißt nix.
Aber meine Top-3 in richtiger Reihenfolge, also ich habe Hertha auf 1 getippt, ich habe Holstein Kiel auf 2 getippt und den VfL Bochum auf Platz 3. So, und bei meinen Absteigern habe ich Magdeburg auf 16, Elbersberg auf 17 und Dresden auf 18.
Ja, sehr schön. Ich habe Hannover auf 1, Karlsruhe auf 2, Fortuna Düsseldorf auf 3.
Das scheiden uns komplett. Krass.
Ja, aber ich finde es cool. Also ich muss auch sagen, mich haben die Tipps, ich fand es sehr witzig, die auch irgendwie einzugeben. Es waren ganz häufig die gleichen Pools an Namen, aber trotzdem immer in unterschiedlicher Reihenfolge. Dann habe ich die SVI auf Platz 16, Preuß Münster auf 17 und Dynamo Dresden auf 18.
Da gleichen wir uns sogar.
Genau, da sind wir tatsächlich gar nicht mehr so weit auseinander. Und ich würde sagen, damit sind wir ja am Ende dieser, durch aus etwas XXL-Folge angekommen, eine Mini-Großvorschau vom Rasenfunk. Aber wir dachten, wir sind euch noch ein bisschen was schuldig.
Eben.
Und wir wollen euch natürlich auch, weil es auch eben im Forum hieß, ja eine Vorschau wäre schön und es bei uns einfach zeitlich nicht reingepasst hat, vom ersten Spieltag das zu machen, wollten wir das zumindest für euch, irgendwie euch noch mit an den Weg geben, obwohl man natürlich immer sagen muss, nach dem ersten Spieltag zu sehen, war natürlich schon irgendwie nochmal ganz cool, um dem damit reinzunehmen, in manchen Bereichen. Hilft, hilft aber auch nicht. Aber ich würde sagen, Marc, das war eine schöne Premiere mit dir hier.
Ey voll. Leider werden wir uns jetzt wieder nicht sprechen wahrscheinlich, weil jetzt geht der normale Modus los, aber es hat mich total gefreut, diesen Anfang mit dir gemacht zu haben.
Ja, mich auf jeden Fall auch. Und ich würde sagen, vielleicht machen wir das noch mal zur Halbserie, dass wir da quasi noch mal zu zweit das Ganze abschließen. Das habe ich jetzt einfach mal in den Raum ohne Abstimmung gehauen. Schon mal als Info, es steht noch nicht ganz fest, aber eventuell die nächste Folge, die erscheint dann erst nach eben der DFB-Bukal-Pause, weil wir haben gesagt, wir brauchen nicht einen Spieltag später direkt wieder eine Folge aufzunehmen. Also wenn dann drei Spieltage gespielt sind, hört ihr uns wieder. Unterstützt den Rasenfunk, kommt gut in diese neue Woche, und wir hören uns bald wieder. Schön, dass wir zurück sind.
Macht's gut!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!